You know, on some levels, Counter-Strike is
a game of numbers, and your health is, obviously,
one of the more important ones.
When it hits zero, your round is over.
But with just one HP left, you can make magic
happen.
I mean who saves guns anyways, right?
I’m Colin for theScore esports and today
we’re talking about insane low health plays
in CS:GO.
Now when we do talk about death-defying plays
in CS, I’m sure a few iconic moments do
spring to mind.
So let’s get this week’s Best of installment
started with the most famous
low HP plays in CS:GO.
(casting)
You know what guys, defending or retaking
a site when you’re playing CT is stressful
enough on its own.
But try doing it with a glowing red
health bar.
(casting)
Now guys, on
T side, things can be even worse.
Not only are you working with a sliver of
health, but you might have to take site all
by your lonesome.
Facing down multiple enemies, with a lot more
health than you have.
(casting)
Well guys that’s all we’ve got for you
this week on Best of.
Now, if your favourite low HP CS:GO play
did not make this compilation, I don’t know
what to tell you.
Go make your own video or something.
See you next week!